holy moly what is this FPS Welcome to
our gaming review of the new 16-inch M2
Max MacBook Pro with the top end 38 core
GPU this system has 32 gigs of RAM which
is definitely enough and in this video
I'm going to test a bunch of games both
fully optimized Apple silicon games
we're gonna have Rosetta two games on
the Mac and we're even playing some
windows only games using crossover which
is an awesome service and you guys are
gonna love this gaming review because
I'm trying to make it super valuable by
including the charts and FPS results
from the M1 Pro and M1 Max Mac web Pro
so you can fully compare the performance
of this new machine now as you can see I
have the MacBook on our partner
grovemade's laptop Riser which I love
because it's made out of Premium
materials like hardwood and aluminum
matching the MacBook aesthetic while
optimizing desk space right here so I
can have my keyboard and my mouse and
the ergonomic so I'm looking directly at
the display so check it out and get 10
off with the link below let's start off
with something easy for this N2 Max ship
it's going to be League of Legends which
is running under Rosetta 2 so it is
using the CPU to do the translation it's
not fully optimized but it should kill
it with this chip all right here we are
in game I'm gonna set the settings to
everything maxed out as high as possible
there you go no frame rate cap I don't
want that turn off the anti-aliasing we
definitely don't need that uh wait for
vertical sync is off there we go
everything's maxed out basically 4K
resolution close to a 3.5 K right while
in the action you could see dang 88 FPS
96 10800 FPS right there 97
honestly it doesn't seem like that big
of an improvement compared to the M1 Max
32 core nice thing is we have not went
below 60 at all so I'd say about 80 to
100 FPS right here when you're kind of
basically fighting people in action 80
to 100 which is nice you do see about
105 sometimes so that's nice but
unfortunately you don't get the full 120
which I honestly would expect with
League of Legends maxed out I mean it is
Rosetta 2 so there is a limitation there
but I would want at least 120 especially
with a 38 core M2 Max now the
interesting thing is when you're just
here in bass 130 120 FPS so definitely a
lot better but as you get closer to the
action gets cut down to about let's say
90 oh 110 right there all right with
that said I do have the scores right
here the M1 Pro 16 core got 61 to 88 FPS
the 32 core M1 Mac that's 75 to 95 and
this M2 Max 30 E8 core gets about 85 to
105 so there is an improvement but not
that big all right the next key we have
is StarCraft 2. once again it's running
under Rosetta 2 so it's not fully
optimized let's see what we get there
you go you can see the exact settings I
have right here with extreme physics and
Ultra effects 120 hertz refresh rate
with vertical sync turned on let's see
how this performs alright so
unfortunately with the 3.5 K the overlay
for FPS is absolutely tiny so I gotta
look close oh oh my goodness 120 FPS
solid right now no problem at all 120fps
solid so now that I'm going out into the
world no issues at all but I am getting
some weird kind of glitchiness where it
kind of like has hiccups I don't know if
that's part of Rosetta 2 issues or
something else all right between 110 and
80 right now while we're fighting in the
ai's base and there you go you can see
how it is compared to the 32 core M1 Max
it's not that much better but there is a
an improvement there running between
around 90 to 110 FPS so now let's run it
at 1080p basically 1920 by 1200 a little
bit higher than 1080P and let's see what
we get and now it is not that much
improved between 110 and 120
consistently here fighting in his base
but it does dip down sometimes to 80 90.
so the interesting thing is that going
down to 1080p 1920 doesn't really help
that much it's around the same maybe a
little bit more consistent but not that
much better than the old M1 Max now the
next game is World of Warcraft which is
native with support for metal Apple
silicon everything we should see huge
gains but before we get into that we've
got to talk a bit about browsing the web
which can be a bit dangerous with
advertisers tracking you and being prone
to hackers but thankfully our sponsor
Opera's web browser fixes that because
it comes with a built-in ad blocker and
a VPN service for free the Opera browser
itself is also really quick and the
sidebar is the most convenient way to
access all of your Social accounts in
one place while feeling secure thanks to
the free VPN which protects your online
privacy unblocks restricted content and
bypasses network restrictions by
changing your IP address to your choice
of three locations keeping your browsing
secure while also being very quick
Snappy and convenient there's also
Opera's VPN Pro which has over 3 000
high-speed servers across 30 unique
locations to protect all of the internet
traffic of up to six of your devices for
only 3.99 a month for a yearly
subscription being cheaper than the
competition and right now Opera is
offering our viewers three free months
of VPN Pro by signing up with this promo
code using the link in the description
below valid on both mobile and desktop
devices and now here we are in World of
Warcraft craft I've set it to 3.5 K full
screen window turn off vertical sync
anti-aliasing is off I've set it to 7
out of 10 Graphics quality just like I
did before with the M1 Max so you can
see everything right here and I have
turned off the maximum FPS I've turned
off Target FPS so it doesn't change
anything and let's see what we can get
holy moly what is this FPS all right the
previous time I also tested in like an
entry World Zone and oh my gosh I can't
believe it you can see it right there
500 FPS we were getting on the 38 core
holy crap now that we're not limited by
Rosetta 2 it is really being Unleashed I
cannot believe it and the fans nothing
500 FPS can't even hear the fans they're
silent I can't believe we're hitting
between 450 to 500 FPS oh my goodness
now previously with these settings the
16 core M1 Pro got about 75 to 85 of FPS
the 32 core M1 Max 146 to 178 and now
we're getting look at that 580 580 FPS
so between 450 to about 550 oh my
goodness I can't believe it that is a
huge difference that is why you're
buying the 38 core M2 Max and now you
know what the M2 Max ship deserves to be
at 10 out of 10 Graphics quality so
let's turn that up right there boom 10
out of 10 same settings on everything
would you look at that maxed out 10 out
of 10 oh my goodness look at that we're
hitting 300 380 FPS right there what in
the world oh my goodness we're hitting
240 200 now that we're fighting but it
did hit 300. okay this is a big range
now I'm seeing 350. so depending on
what's on the screen it does go between
let's say 240 to about
320. and can you believe it the 32 core
M1 Max only hit about 96 to 105 FPS so
this is on a whole nother level
this chip is finally the one where you
can get insane FPS playing these games
this is definitely going to be good
enough for the raids and everything else
now moving on before I get into these
cross over Windows games Grand Theft
Auto 5 and The Witcher 3. I do want to
test a couple of more Rosetta 2 games
specifically Dota 2 and CS go and here
we are in CS go you can see my settings
right here we got full screen 1920x1200
here are the advanced video settings a
lot of them set to medium for now with
of course vertical sync disabled and
motion blur as well so let's get right
into a match alright guys right off the
bat I'm impressed look at that 165 we
just saw 118 right there I just saw 89
I'm actually spectating right now 108
813 very good mostly it's over 100 122
right there so very good FPS so far 89
actually right there I just saw 89 and
that's a pretty good Improvement because
with the 32 core M1 Max I saw 62 as the
FPS low I'm getting 141 right there I
just saw 141. so we just got a high of
141 compared to 129 so not a big
difference here but let's turn up the
graphics let's just go ahead and Max it
out 3.5 K like I did on the other games
let's see what we get are you kidding I
can't even see the FPS it's over a
hundred though FPS is over 100 at 3.5 K
and see us go so 90 right there it does
dip down a little bit but over a hundred
not bad 3.5 K res all right I played for
a little bit and it looks like it gets
between around 90 to 105 FPS so keep in
mind this is Rosetta 2 limited once
again so not that big of an improvement
compared to the 32 core M1 Max in CS go
here we are in the settings just like
last time I'm setting it to 2560 by 1600
120 hertz exclusive full screen setting
it to the best looking settings all
right we're getting right into it it
looks like 100 17 FPS is the highest
I've seen it's at oh 98 it just hit
right there so 98 to 117 FPS 104 FPS
105. oh so close all right so with these
settings 98 to 117 which is weird
because it's exactly what we got on the
32 core M1 Max so let's turn up the
settings there you go we're gonna Max it
out 3.5 K once again boom apply now the
FPS counter is tiny looking at 90 FPS
now with 3.5 K resolution everything
looks amazing all right guys this is
weird man because I saw about 89 to 95
that's almost exactly what we got on the
32 core M1 Max so it looks like this
game is limited by Rosetta 2. absolutely
do not upgrade to the M2 Max chip if
you're playing DOTA 2. and now before we
get into those crossover Windows games
we've got to play the brand new resin
Resident Evil Village which just came
out so I didn't play it on the previous
machine but this has full metal three
Apple silicon support this might be the
most optimized game alongside World of
Warcraft for these Apple silicon
machines all right here we are I can't
believe it you can use HDR mode in this
game finally a game that supports the
1600 nit display because that spot right
there is insanely bright I'm setting it
to 3.5 K 120 FPS vsync I want off
upscaling is off let's turn up that
image quality all the way to two you can
see it's using a good amount of the vram
look at that eight gigs we don't need no
anti-aliasing
texture quality turn it up using a bunch
of that Ram right there I'm maxing it
all out I don't even care oh the fans
are heating up I'm in the menus I've
maxed everything out all the settings
fully maxed out all right so here we are
and this definitely feels
like not 60 FPS I'm not getting an FPS
counter but man that feels choppy yeah
just going like this the fans of this
thing are getting hot all right I think
this is Extreme like look at that the
FPS is pretty low let me actually turn
down the controls going back to image
quality one because it was too crazy
texture quality can be high one gig
let's turn some of this stuff down mesh
quality mid Shadow quality mid yeah
let's turn this stuff down let's see
what happens there you go that's better
I don't know exactly how much but this
is definitely at least 60. that's a lot
better so max Graphics it's unplayable
this right here is great still 3.5 K
keep that in mind so still really really
good and now it's Grand Theft Auto 5
time let's jump right into it here we
are in the graphic settings we have
1920x1200 because this is a Windows game
through crossover so it's using molten
VK to translate the windows based apis
to metal which takes a lot of processing
and of course Rosetta 2 as well and you
can see the settings right here I'm
matching it up to the ones that I played
with on the M1 Max now get into the
story mode everything seems super smooth
there is a little bit of glitches which
I think is from the crossover
translation but overall it's over 60 FPS
all the time so that is very good in
reassuring alright so here we are and we
are getting some occasional glitching
from crossover but the actual FPS look
at that so the crossover glitching with
it kind of just like stuttering a little
bit every now and then is annoying but
it's like like that but as far as when
it actually is playing super smooth I
mean it's above 60 for sure all the time
very very smooth like it's fast like it
might even be like 90. look at that
super fast that is a big Improvement
compared to before yeah this is
definitely an improvement between 60 and
90 for sure I'd say even like 80 to 90
FPS that's a big Improvement in
crossover compared to the 32 core M1 Max
which got between 50 to 55 it didn't
even get solid 60. this is nice between
60 to 90 for sure that is playable
finally with Grand Theft Auto 5. and now
finally for Witcher 3 we are getting
some errors and it is not turning on I'm
not sure why or maybe this is a new
version of crossover that somehow messed
it up not sure but it is not running but
we do know that Grand Theft Auto 5
improved a good amount on the M2 Max
through crossover so we do know there
are some benefits in terms of that as
well so with all of that said let me get
into my final conclusion with the M2 Max
is it worth buying this 38 core and
upgrade trading if you want to do some
gaming well if you don't already have
the previous M1 Pro or M1 Max machines
then this is going to be great for
getting into Apple silicon gaming it has
a lot of performance but if you already
have one and you're playing games
through Rosetta 2 the difference is not
that big maybe 10 15 20 in some of the
games some games like Dota 2 didn't
really improve at all but if you're
playing metal optimized games for
example World of Warcraft we saw a
massive massive difference it is totally
worth upgrading from the M1 Max to the
new M2 max if you play World of Warcraft
or other optimized metal games and of
course games like Resident Evil Village
if you fine-tune the settings work great
on this thing 3.5 K resolution it's
insane it definitely worked just fine
and unfortunately there aren't that many
metal optimized games so if you're going
to be doing some gaming just go buy a
win Windows laptop instead so you can
have full support for all the games you
want because still we have a lack of
support for games and that is
disappointing so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this gaming review of the M2 Max
16 inch let me know what you think down
in the comment section below click the
circle button to subscribe for more
videos like this one and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]